Up to 4% of people in the U.S. live with bipolar disorder, what used to be called manic depression. But as common as this mood disorder is, it is also often misunderstood and misdiagnosed. Indeed, many people with bipolar disorder wait years between experiencing their first symptoms and receiving an accurate diagnosis. And the general public perception that bipolar disorder is always severe and untreatable is both harmful and out of date. For the past few decades, researchers have made great strides in understanding how to recognize, diagnose, and treat bipolar disorder with both psychotherapy and medications.
在美国，高达4%的人患有双相情感障碍，也就是以前所说的躁郁症。但尽管这种情绪障碍很常见，它也常常被误解和误诊。事实上，许多双相情感障碍患者从体验到第一批症状到确诊需要等待数年时间。公众普遍认为双相情感障碍总是病情严重且无法治疗，这种看法既有害又过时。在过去的几十年里，研究人员在理解如何通过心理疗法和药物识别、诊断和治疗双相情感障碍方面取得了巨大进展。
So what are the symptoms of bipolar disorder and how is it diagnosed? At what age do symptoms usually first appear? What does bipolar disorder look like in children and teens versus adults? What treatments are available? And is bipolar disorder linked to creativity or is that just a myth? Is it genetic or something that people develop as a result of trauma? And what are researchers learning about helping people with bipolar disorder manage it and live healthy, productive lives?
那么双相情感障碍的症状是什么，它是如何被诊断的？症状通常在什么年龄首次出现？儿童和青少年与成年人的双相情感障碍有什么区别？有哪些可用的治疗方法？双相情感障碍与创造力有关吗，还是这只是一种神话？它是基因决定的，还是人们因遭受创伤而发展出来的？研究人员在帮助双相情感障碍患者管理病情并过上健康、有生产力的生活方面正在了解什么？
Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today. The first is Dr. David Micklewitz, a clinical psychologist and professor in the Department of psychiatry at the University of California, Los Angeles Semmel Institute. Dr. Micklewitz treats and conducts research with people who have bipolar disorder and their families. Much of his research focuses on family's psychoeducational treatments for childhood onset bipolar disorder. He's won many
欢迎收听《心理学对话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。今天我们请到了两位嘉宾。第一位是大卫·米克洛维茨博士（Dr. David Miklowitz），他是一位临床心理学家，也是加利福尼亚大学洛杉矶分校塞梅尔研究所精神病学系的教授。米克洛维茨博士为双相情感障碍患者及其家属提供治疗并开展相关研究。他的许多研究都集中在针对儿童期发病的双相情感障碍的家庭心理教育治疗上。他曾获得过许多
awards for his research and has published more than 300 research articles and eight books, including guides to bipolar disorder for both clinicians and patients. His best-selling book, The Bipolar, Polar Disorder Survival Guide is in its third edition with more than 300,000 copies in print. Our second guest is writer and mental health advocate Terry Cheney. Ms. Cheney has chronicled her lifelong experience with bipolar disorder in three books, Manic, a memoir, The Dark Side of Innocence Growing Up Bipolar, and Her Recent Modern Madness and Owners Manual. A 2008 column that she wrote for the New York Times about living with bipolar disorder was adapted into an episode of the Netflix television series Modern Love.
与其研究相关的奖项，并发表了300多篇研究论文和8本书，其中包括为临床医生和患者编写的双相情感障碍指南。他的畅销书《双相情感障碍生存指南》（The Bipolar Disorder Survival Guide）已经出了第三版，印刷量超过30万册。我们的第二位嘉宾是作家兼心理健康倡导者特里·切尼（Terry Cheney）。切尼女士在三本书中记录了她一生与双相情感障碍相处的经历，这些书包括回忆录《躁狂》（Manic）、《纯真的阴暗面：在双相中长大》（The Dark Side of Innocence Growing Up Bipolar）以及她最近出版的《现代疯狂与使用说明书》（Modern Madness and Owners Manual）。她2008年为《纽约时报》撰写的一篇关于与双相情感障碍共存的专栏文章被改编成了网飞（Netflix）电视剧《现代爱情》（Modern Love）中的一集。
Before becoming a writer and mental health advocate, she worked for many years as an entertainment attorney in Los Angeles. Thank you both for joining me today. Thank you. Thanks for having us. Thank you, Kim. It's great to be here. Let's start with the basics, Dr. McCliewicz. Could you give us an overview of how bipolar disorder is defined and diagnosed? I know there are several different subty.
在成为作家和心理健康倡导者之前，她曾在洛杉矶担任多年的娱乐法律师。非常感谢两位今天能加入我的节目。谢谢。谢谢邀请我们。谢谢金。很高兴来到这里。让我们从基础知识开始，米克洛维茨博士。您能否概述一下双相情感障碍是如何定义和诊断的？我知道有几种不同的子类。
in the diagnostic and statistical manual of mental disorders. What do they have in common and how are they different? Okay. Bipolar disorder used to be called manic depression. It's one of our oldest psychiatric disorders been recognized, really since the 1800s, perhaps even before. And it's characterized by very severe mood swings from what we call mania to depression.
在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》中。它们有什么共同点，又有什么不同？好的。双相情感障碍以前被称为躁郁症。它是我们最古老的精神疾病之一，实际上自19世纪以来就已被人们认识到，甚至可能更早。它的特征是情绪会有非常严重的波动，从我们所说的躁狂到抑郁。
In states of mania, people have a constant. people have a couple of weeks or maybe even months of having very high mood or extreme irritability. Their moods really are kind of out of control. With that is kind of a sped-up energetic feeling. They feel like they have lots of energy. They don't feel as much need to sleep. They could go nights without sleeping or sleep very little. Grandios ideas or what we call inflated self.
在躁狂状态下，人们有持续的。人们会有几周甚至几个月的高涨情绪或极度易怒。他们的情绪确实有点失控。随之而来的是一种加速的、充满精力的感觉。他们觉得自己有大量的精力。他们觉得对睡眠的需求没那么多了。他们可以连续几个夜晚不睡觉或者只睡很少。有夸大的想法，或者我们所说的膨胀的自。
esteem, the sort of sense of having extra powers or even believing that you're a famous person. Hypersexuality is often goes along with it as excessive sex drive or impulsive behavior like spending, speaking very fast. It's a very sped-up state. Now, those episodes alternate with depressions, which most of us are more familiar with, but it's more than just sadness. It's depressed mood, depressive clinical states involving slowed down, fatigued, excessive sleeping, or having insomnia, perhaps, depression, loss of interest in things, nothing is fun, loss of concentration, and often suicidal thinking or behavior. And people with bipolar disorder alternate between those.
尊心，那种拥有超能力的感觉，甚至相信自己是个名人。高性欲通常也伴随着这种状态，表现为过度的性欲或冲动行为，比如花钱、语速极快。这是一种高度加速的状态。现在，这些发作与抑郁症交替出现，我们大多数人对抑郁症更熟悉，但它不仅仅是悲伤。它是抑郁心境、抑郁临床状态，表现为行动迟缓、疲劳、睡眠过多，或者可能失眠、抑郁、失去对事物的兴趣、觉得什么都没意思、注意力减退，并且经常有自杀的想法或行为。双相情感障碍患者就在这些。
two extremes. There are people who have both at the same time, we call them mixed, if they've had both mania and depression at the same time. We also have a, some people would say it's a milder form, although that's some question of debate, bipolar two disorder, which is a variation between severe depression in hypomania, hypomania being less severe version of mania, less likely to cause impairment, even though the same symptoms may be there. So we have, we think it's about two to three percent of the population that has this disorder in some form. Does that sound right to you, Ms. Cheney? And what does it feel like to cycle between these mood states?
两种极端之间交替。有些人同时具备这两种状态，如果他们同时经历过躁狂和抑郁，我们称之为混合状态。我们还有一种——有些人会说这是一种较温和的形式，尽管这还有一些争议——II型双相情感障碍，这是严重抑郁与轻躁狂之间的变异，轻躁狂是躁狂的较不严重版本，不太可能导致功能受损，尽管可能会出现相同的症状。因此我们认为，大约2%到3%的人口以某种形式患有这种疾病。切尼女士，这听起来对吗？在这些情绪状态之间循环是什么感觉？
I think that covered most of the territory. I would add that in mania, it's not the fun, euphoric, exciting state. Most people think it is. There's a lot of agitation and irritability that goes along with it. and certainly with mixed states as well, I think that mostly people understand depression better than mania. So that's the big mystery is what is mania really like. What do we know about the causes of bipolar disorder? Is it, as I mentioned in the intro, I was asking whether it's genetic or can it be precipitated by some kind of a traumatic life experience or childhood experience or is it something that runs in families?
我认为这涵盖了大部分内容。我想补充一点，在躁狂状态下，它并不是大多数人认为的那种有趣、欣快、令人兴奋的状态。其中伴随着大量的焦虑和易怒。当然混合状态也是如此，我认为人们对抑郁症的理解通常比对躁狂症的理解要好。所以最大的谜团是躁狂究竟是什么样的。我们对双相情感障碍的成因了解多少？正如我在开场白中所提到的，它是遗传的，还是可以由某种创伤性的生活经历或童年经历引发，抑或是家族遗传的？
I would say this. It is a combination of genetic, biological, and social. It certainly runs in families. People inherit a predisposition to bipolar disorder. They don't necessarily have bipolar people in their family that they can identify. But often there's somebody in the family tree who's had this disorder. Sometimes it's a grandparent. Sometimes it's a parent. And certainly depression. also runs in those families. So we have good reason to believe it's genetic. And some genetic markers have been found, DNA markers. There is also evidence for environmental stress triggering those vulnerabilities. So people who have the vulnerability may have a childhood experience. It may trigger the psychophysiological dysfunctions that are characteristic of the disorder. So we're sort of thinking about it as you come into this world with a vulnerability.
我会这样说。它是遗传、生物和社会因素的结合。它绝对具有家族聚集性。人们会遗传对双相情感障碍的易感性。他们的家族中不一定能识别出明确患有双相情感障碍的人。但通常在家族谱系中曾有人得过这种病。有时是祖父母。有时是父母。当然，抑郁症也经常在这些家族中出现。所以我们有充分的理由相信它是遗传的。并且已经发现了一些遗传标记，即DNA标记。也有证据表明环境压力会触发这些脆弱性。因此，具有这种脆弱性的人可能会经历某种童年经历。它可能会触发该疾病特征性的心理生理功能障碍。所以我们大致这样认为：你带着脆弱性来到这个世界。
vulnerability, certain life events can make it worse or trigger it in the first place or keep it, make it more recurrent. So both are important. Does that ring true for you, Terry? Are there people in your family who have been diagnosed with bipolar disorder in addition to you? No one in my family that I'm aware of was diagnosed with bipolar disorder, which doesn't mean they didn't have it. They just weren't diagnosed because it wasn't paid much attention to previously. But I certainly felt that I had it, even as a very young child, I had a suicide attempt at age seven. So for me, it went way back.
脆弱性，某些生活事件可能会使其恶化，或在一开始触发它，或者使其更容易复发。因此两者都很重要。特里，这听起来对你来说真实吗？除了你之外，你家里还有人被诊断出患有双相情感障碍吗？据我所知，我家里没有人被诊断出患有双相情感障碍，这并不意味着他们没有。他们只是没有被诊断出来，因为以前没有得到太多关注。但我确实觉得我有这种病，甚至在一个很小的孩子时，我在7岁时就有过一次自杀未遂。所以对我来说，这可以追溯到很久以前。
So at what age do people tend to first experience symptoms of bipolar disorder? David, maybe you could answer that one. Yeah, so that's been a topic of some debate in the last couple of decades. We used to think bipolar disorder didn't have onset till the early 20s, but now more and more university sites and clinics are seeing this disorder in adolescence. And even sometimes in kids, that's where there's the biggest debate is, is this, you know, does this occur in young children? And some people say it's right.
那么人们通常在什么年龄首次经历双相情感障碍的症状？大卫，也许你可以回答这个问题。是的，所以在过去的几十年里，这一直是一个有争议的话题。我们曾经认为双相情感障碍直到20多岁才发病，但现在越来越多的大学医疗点和诊所开始在青少年中看到这种疾病。甚至有时在儿童中也会看到，这也是争议最大的地方，就是这个，你知道的，这会发生在幼儿身上吗？有些人说这是对的。
It happens regularly. Some people say it's very rare. My own experience is it's pretty rare, but it does occur. where we see more of it is an adolescence, where people have their first manic episode or their first depressive episode. Sometimes it's that they had a mild depressive episode in adolescence and then a more severe mania when they become young adults, or they have one of these hypomanic episodes in childhood and then a major depression during adolescence. So the average age of onset is, nationally is about 18, but there's quite a bit of variability anywhere from, you know, at the low end
它经常发生。有些人说这非常罕见。我自己的经验是，它相当罕见，但确实会发生。我们更多看到的是在青少年时期，人们经历了他们的第一次躁狂发作或第一次抑郁发作。有时是他们在青少年时期经历过轻度抑郁发作，然后在成为年轻成年人时出现更严重的躁狂，或者他们在童年时期经历过轻躁狂发作之一，然后在青少年时期出现重度抑郁。因此，全国平均发病年龄约为18岁，但有相当大的变异性，从低端。
12, at the high end, 25. And how do you treat children with something like bipolar disorder? I mean, one of the class of treatments, and we'll get into this a little bit more, is about, is, is, drugs, but, you know, it's very controversial as to whether you give drugs to very young children. Well, if it's a very young child, we don't come in with all guns blazing, so to speak. You don't necessarily give the strongest medications. If it's unquestionably bipolar disorder, you know, you're really seeing a kid that needs to be in the hospital or he or she is suicidal or they're unable to function in the home or at school, you might try a medicine, which might be an antipsychotic or it might be a miscotic or it might be a miscotic. mood stabilizer, but generally we like to not jump in with the heaviest medications at first. By adolescence, when the disorder has kind of declared itself and we're already seeing
12岁，到高端25岁。你如何治疗患有类似双相情感障碍的儿童？我的意思是，其中一类治疗方法——我们稍后会更深入地探讨——是关于药物的，但是，你知道的，给极小的儿童使用药物是非常有争议的。嗯，如果是非常小的孩子，我们不会一上来就火力全开，可以这么说。你不一定要给最强效的药物。如果毫无疑问是双相情感障碍，你知道的，你真的看到一个孩子需要住院，或者他或她有自杀倾向，或者他们在家里或学校无法功能运作，你可能会尝试一种药物，可能是抗精神病药物，或者它可能是一种。心境稳定剂，但总的来说，我们倾向于一开始不直接使用最重的药物。到了青少年时期，当这种疾病已经表现出来，并且我们已经看到了。
cycling patterns, that's when we're usually introducing a mood stabilizer or an antipsychotic. And it's a hard emotional question to address for the kid and the family about taking medicines and how long do you take them for and what happens if you don't take them. Some people prefer the kind of wait and see, let's see what happens over time. But if the kid is being very self-destructive, then you may not have that option. It's very tough on parents when they have to make that decision. So let me ask you, Terry, how old were you when you first experienced symptoms? I mean, you mentioned a suicide attempt at seven.
循环模式时，这通常是我们引入心境稳定剂或抗精神病药物的时候。对于孩子和家庭来说，这是一个艰难的情感问题，要处理服药问题，要吃多久，以及如果不吃会发生什么。有些人更喜欢“走着瞧”的态度，看看随着时间推移会发生什么。但如果孩子有很强的自残倾向，那么你可能就没有那种选择了。当父母必须做出这个决定时，这非常艰难。所以我想问你，特里，你第一次经历症状时几岁？我的意思是，你提到过7岁时有一次自杀未遂。
Was that really the onset? and then how long did it take for you to actually get diagnosed and get help? Well, I had classic symptoms of cycling throughout my childhood, where I would, particularly with depression, where I would fall into these states where I couldn't get out of bed, couldn't go to school. Those would last a few weeks, and then I'd come roaring back to life
那是真正的发病吗？然后你花了多长时间才真正确诊并获得帮助？嗯，在我的整个童年时期，我都有循环发作的典型症状，尤其是在抑郁方面，我会陷入这些状态中，起不了床，无法去上学。这些状态会持续几周，然后我又会生龙活虎地恢复过来。
and do all these extra credit reports and all to make up what I'd missed. So it took, unfortunately, until I was 34 years old, before I got a diagnosis, and it was the wrong diagnosis, as so often happens, it was major depression because that's how I presented to the doctor. You don't go in when you're manic because you're feeling so high. So all the doctor saw was my depression and treated me for that. Was that at least helpful? At the time, it did help somewhat, yes, but it also, I think, triggered, I was on an antidepressant, and I think it triggered cycling, which, can happen if you're not treated properly with a mood stabilizer.
并完成所有这些额外的学分报告来弥补我错过的东西。所以，不幸的是，直到我34岁时，我才得到诊断，而且是错误的诊断，就像经常发生的那样，那是重度抑郁症，因为这就是我在医生面前呈现出的样子。当你处于躁狂状态时你不会去看医生，因为你感觉太棒了。所以医生看到的只是我的抑郁症并为此治疗了我。这至少有帮助吗？当时确实在某种程度上提供了帮助，是的，但我也认为它引发了——我当时在服用抗抑郁药，我认为它引发了循环，如果不通过心境稳定剂进行适当治疗，这种情况是可能会发生的。
So, David, what are the effective treatments? Can we talk about that a little bit? Sure. Well, there's the medicines and then there's the psychotherapies. And the medicines that we found are most effective are mood stabilizers in that category are drugs like lithium, valproic acid or valproate, which is also called depicote. Lomotrogen, which is also called lomyctyl. Those are mood stabilizers. And interestingly, they also have a role in the treatment of epilepsy, at least limitol and depicotone do.
那么，大卫，有哪些有效的治疗方法？我们能稍微谈谈这个吗？当然。嗯，有药物治疗，还有心理疗法。我们发现最有效的药物是心境稳定剂，这一类别的药物包括锂盐、丙戊酸或丙戊酸钠（也称为德巴金/Depakote）。拉莫三嗪（也称为利必通/Lamictal）。这些都是心境稳定剂。有趣的是，它们在癫痫的治疗中也发挥作用，至少利必通和德巴金是这样的。
Then we have the antipsychotics, which are drugs like rospadone, areapypipersol, latuda, various drugs that are used. really usually in the acute manic phase to kind of bring someone down from mania, the person may continue on them for longer to be able to stabilize their symptoms, but we don't like to have people on those forever because they have side effects like weight gain, fatigue, agitation, sometimes. All these drugs have some side effects. We do bring in antidepressants once in a while if a person has a very treatment-resistant
然后我们有抗精神病药物，比如利培酮、阿立哌唑、芦替拉酮等各种药物。通常在急性躁狂阶段使用，以将某人的躁狂状态压制下来，患者可能会继续服用较长时间以稳定症状，但我们不喜欢让患者永远服用这些药物，因为它们有副作用，比如体重增加、疲劳、有时还有烦躁。所有这些药物都有一些副作用。如果患者对治疗有很强的抵抗力，我们偶尔会引入抗抑郁药。
depression. But the problem with antidepressants, as Terry was alluding to, is they can increase cycling. They can cause more rapid cycling, more switches from high to low. Then there's psychotherapy. Our particular brand that we've tested in our lab is a family-focused therapy, oriented towards functioning within the family, getting the family to understand what bipolar disorder is, how to communicate about it, how to be supportive without taking over for the person, how to encourage medication compliance without being controlling, how to recognize an early warning sign when it's developing. All that can, the family can be of considerable help in that process. Other people prefer to go the individual route and have an individual therapist who's helping
抑郁症。但正如特里所暗示的，抗抑郁药的问题在于它们会增加循环。它们会导致更快速的循环，从高涨到低落的转换更频繁。然后是心理疗法。我们在实验室中测试的特定疗法是以家庭为中心的治疗，侧重于家庭内部的功能运作，让家庭了解什么是双相情感障碍、如何就此进行沟通、如何在不接管患者生活的情况下给予支持、如何在不具有控制欲的情况下鼓励依从服药、如何在病情发展时识别早期预警信号。所有这些，家庭都可以在这个过程中提供相当大的帮助。其他人更愿意走个人路线，找一个独立治疗师，在患有这种疾病的情况下帮助他们建立自我认同，或者找一个认知行为治疗师，与他们一起处理他们的自我对话或归因。我认为小组对于双相情感障碍患者非常有用，特别是如果其中包含其他也有这种疾病的人，这可以为他们提供关于如何应对的建议。所以最有效的治疗方法是药物和心理疗法的结合。特里，这也是你正在做的吗？你是在进行两者的结合吗？而且我知道你也写过关于在很长一段时间内服用大量不同药物的“鸡尾酒”疗法的文章，你如何应对这种情况？
them kind of with their identity formation despite having this disorder or a cognitive behavioral therapists who might work with them on their self-talk or their attributions. Groups, I think, are very useful for people with bipolar disorder, especially if they involve other people who have the disorder and it can give them advice on how to cope. So most effective treatments are a combination of medications and psychotherapy. And is that what you're doing, Terry? is are you doing a combination of both? And I know you've also written about sort of taking a cocktail of a lot of different drugs over a long period of time, and how do you deal with that?
应对手头的药物需求可能非常困难，但我认为如果你患有双相情感障碍，服药是必要的。对我来说，知道有药物可以帮助我，也减轻了污名感。这感觉像是，好吧，我的大脑里确实有些明确的问题是可以修复的。当然，药物对我产生了巨大的帮助，尽管我想补充关于抗精神病药物的一点，对于外行人来说，这是一个可怕的词，因为我从未精神错乱过。但事实上，事实证明是一种抗精神病药——阿立哌唑——对我帮助最大。所以你只需要对医生的建议保持开放的心态。治疗对我也至关重要。
It can be very difficult to deal with the medication requirement, but I think it is necessary to be on medication if you're bipolar. It also, for me, felt less stigmatic to know that there was a medication that could help me. It felt like, okay, there was something definitively wrong in my brain that could be fixed. And certainly I've been helped tremendously by medication, although I'd like to add about antipsychotics that that's a terrifying word for a lay person to hear because I was never psychotic. But in fact, it turned out to be an antipsychotic ericip resolved. It helped me the most. So you just have to be open to your doctor's advice. Therapy has been essential for me.
我接受了30年的治疗，包括团体治疗、常规治疗，以及米克洛维茨博士提到的所有治疗。我都做过。我想我现在正在发现的——而且我现在做得很好——正念是我的康复中非常重要的一部分。仅仅是学会试着活在当下，不要有太多的判断，不对未来感到焦虑。这确实很有帮助。这是一种越来越普遍的治疗方法吗，米克洛维茨博士？是的，确实如此。我们对此做过一些研究，其他人也做过。正念，即正念认知疗法，已被发现对重度抑郁症有效，并且能。
I've been in therapy for 30 years, group therapy, regular therapy, everything that Dr. Miklowitz mentioned. I've done it all. And I think what I'm discovering now and I'm doing very well now is mindfulness is a huge part of my recovery. Just learning to try to stay in the moment without too much judgment, without anxiety about the future. It really has been helpful. Is that a treatment that's becoming more common, Dr. McCluret? Yes, it is. We've done some studies on it, and others have as well. It's mindfulness, mindfulness-based cognitive therapy has been found to be effective for major depression and
预防重度抑郁症复发。有一些初步证据表明它对双相情感障碍也可能有效。目前尚不清楚它是否像预防抑郁那样有效地预防躁狂。实际上，这正是我要问你的，特里，你是否觉得正念在躁狂阶段也有帮助，它是否能很好地帮助你从高涨状态中平静下来？我对这个有一个有趣的反应。我其实觉得正念让我快乐得多。有时我认为我是轻躁狂，这是躁狂之下的状态，你感觉极好，生活非常顺利，你觉得自己处于最佳状态。所以我非常好奇，米克洛维茨博士，你是否听说过正念导致轻躁狂，
preventing recurrences of major depression. There's some beginning evidence that it might be effective for bipolar disorder as well. It's not clear that it prevents mania as well as it prevents depression. That's actually what I was going to ask you, Terry, is whether or not you feel like the mindfulness helps during the manic phase as well, whether it helps bring you down from a high well. I have an interesting response to that. I think actually that mindfulness makes me so much happier. Sometimes I think I'm hypomanic, which is the state just below mania, where you're feeling terrific and life is going really well and you feel on top of your game. So I'm very curious, Dr. McLewitz, if you ever heard of mindfulness causing hypomania,
还是这只是我正在经历的一个极好的副作用？我没有看到任何相关数据，但我听别人说过。我听说过参加过小组的人说这给了他们特殊的洞察力，他们对这些洞察力感到非常兴奋。所以我认为就像任何抗抑郁药一样，也许它就像抗抑郁药物。当你改善情绪时，你也会面临将某人推入躁狂状态的风险。但没有相关数据。其他生活方式因素呢，比如保持规律睡眠或避免饮酒？
or is that just a great side effect I'm experiencing? I haven't seen any data on it, but I've heard people say it. I've heard people who've been in the groups say that it gives them special insights, and they get very sort of excited about those insights. So I think like any antidepressant, maybe it's like antidepressant medication. When you improve mood, you also have the risk of setting someone into mania. But there's no date on it. What about other lifestyle factors such as getting regular sleep or avoiding alcohol?
特里，你谈到了避免饮酒对你来说有多重要。还有其他你觉得真的需要避免的诱惑吗？是的，我已经戒酒23年了，直到我停止饮酒后，我的药物才真正开始起作用。这对我来说是个彻底的打击，因为我以为不喝酒和同时服用这种药物只是一种建议。事实证明，我的大脑化学反应确实需要没有酒精来干扰药物。但至于其他生活方式因素，睡眠是至关重要的。对于患有双相情感障碍的我来说，睡眠一直是一件困难的事情。但有趣的是，我发现当我经历更年期时，当我开始使用荷尔蒙。
Terry, you've talked about how important it is for you to avoid alcohol. Are there other triggers that you feel you really need to avoid? Yes, I've been sober for 23 years, and it wasn't until I stopped drinking that my medications actually began to work. And that was a total shock to me because I thought it was just a suggestion that you not drink alcohol and take this drug at the same time. It turned out to be that my brain chemistry just really needed to not have the alcohol interfering with the medication. But as far as other lifestyle factors, sleep is critical. Sleep has always been a difficult thing for me with bipolar disorder. but interestingly enough, I found when I went through menopause that when I got on hormonal
药物后，我的睡眠改善了，我的双相情感障碍也有所改善。所以这是一件需要检查的事情。还有，甲状腺——检查我的甲状腺也很重要，这会影响我的双相情感障碍。所以所有这些因素都是相互关联的。如果你想在精神上保持健康，我认为你需要过健康的生活方式。我能对此补充一点吗？可以，如果你愿意的话，请说。是的。我同意特里所说的一切，我认为她关于酒精所说的一切也可以。
medications, my sleep improved and my bipolar disorder improved as well. So it's a thing to check out. Also, thyroid has, checking on my thyroid has been important that can impact my bipolar disorder. So there are all these interrelated factors. You need to live a healthy lifestyle. If you want to want to be healthy mentally, I think. Can I add to that as well? Yeah, if you would, yeah. Yeah. I agree with everything Terry said, and I think everything she said about alcohol could also
适用于大麻。有些人持续吸大麻，他们认为这是一种心境稳定剂，但实际上它以其独特的方式助长了你的情绪循环。如果没别的，它会干扰睡眠，有些人嗨了之后就睡不着觉，或者这会让他们在白天感到疲劳，所以他们会小睡。当你同时服用精神科药物时，任何滥用物质都不是一件好事，原因有多种。我们向双相情感障碍患者推荐的首要事情之一，就是尝试保持规律的睡眠-觉醒周期，这说起来容易，但实际上非常非常困难。
apply to marijuana. There are people who smoke weed consistently, and they're thinking it's a mood stabilizer, but actually it can, in its own way, contribute to your mood cycling. If nothing else, by interfering with sleep, some people get high and then they can't fall asleep or it makes them sort of fatigue during the day so they take naps. There are various reasons why any substance of abuse is not a good thing to do when you're also taking psychiatric medications. One of the first things we recommend to people with bipolar disorders to try to stay on a regular sleep wake cycle, which sounds easy when you say it, but it actually is very, very difficult
因为首先这种疾病会干扰睡眠，当你患有这种疾病时很难入睡，而且你可能是轻躁狂，你的大脑可能会运转很快，或者你可能会感到抑郁，发现如果没有小睡很难熬过这一天。因此，首要策略之一就是试图让人们把就寝时间和起床时间控制在一定范围内，这样他们就不会睡过头，或者，你知道的，我们称之为“睡眠暴饮暴食”。现在有一种观点认为，双相情感障碍，特别是双相情感障碍的躁狂阶段，与创造力甚至创造天才有关。这有什么真实性吗，还是这只是一种神话？
because first the disorder interferes with sleep and it's hard to get to sleep when you have the disorder and also you may be hypomanic, your mind may be going fast or you may be depressed and find it hard to get through the day without having a nap. So one of the first strategies is to try to get people to have their bedtime within a certain range and their wake-up time within a certain range so they don't oversleep or, you know, sleep binge, as we call it. Now, there's an idea that bipolar disorder, particularly the manic phase of bipolar disorder, is linked to creativity and even creative genius. Is there any truth to that, or is that just a myth?
你想回答这个吗，特里？我想插话并说，我认为绝对存在一种联系。在我的出版生涯中，我认识了许多许多双相情感障碍患者。在我心中，艺术与双相情感障碍普遍存在某种联系，不一定非得是躁狂。但当你患有双相情感障碍时，会发生一些事情。当你是一个艺术家时，它们会给你带来额外的优势。
Do you want to answer that, Terry? I'd like to jump in and say, I think there's an absolute connection. I have known many, many bipolar people. over the course of my publishing career. And certainly there is a connection in my mind to artistry and just bipolar disorder in general, not necessarily mania. But there are things that happen when you're bipolar. They give you an extra edge when you're an artist.
因为你遭受了如此多的痛苦，所以你培养了极大的同理心。你可以把这一点带入你的艺术中。我认为当你患有双相情感障碍时，你在某种程度上也是一个局外人。这能让你观察人们，然后，你知道的，试图找出什么是正常行为。这也有助于创造力。所以我认为患有双相情感障碍的很多方面都与创造力息息相关。是的，我也赞同这一点。
You develop a great deal of empathy because you've suffered so much. And so you can bring that to your art. I think you also are somewhat of an outsider when you're bipolar. And that allows you to watch people and, you know, trying to find out what's a normal behavior. That also helps with creativity. So I think there's a lot of that being bipolar that is connected to creativity. Yes. And I would agree with that.
当然有许多历史人物患有双相情感障碍。至少当我们回看时，他们看起来确实患有双相情感障碍。各种画家、古典音乐家柴可夫斯基、贝多芬，我们认为可能都患有双相情感障碍。库尔特·柯本（Kurt Cobain），更近一些，可能也患有双相情感障碍。这种联系——尽管我们认为人们可能在轻躁狂期间比在躁狂期间创造更多。
Certainly there is many. historical figures who've had bipolar disorder. At least when we look back, it certainly looks like they had bipolar disorder. Various painters, Chikowsky, the classic musician, the Beethoven, we think, probably had bipolar disorder. Kurt Cobain, more recently, had probably had bipolar disorder. And the linkage, though we think it may be that people create more during hypomania than mania,
因为这确实能帮你稍微加速，你的想法运转得更快，当你处于轻躁狂状态时，你会更有跳出常规思考的倾向。但当你陷入躁狂时，我不知道特里是否同意这一点，但我认为人们会产出很多作品，但那并不是他们最好的作品。绝对的，我同意这一点。当我处于轻躁狂时，我能看到事物之间的联系。这太惊人了。
because it certainly helps you to speed up a little bit, and your thoughts go faster, and you kind of think outside the box a little bit more when you're hypomanic. But when you get manic, I don't know if Terry would agree with this, but I think people produce a lot of work, but it's not their best work. Absolutely, I'd agree with that. When I'm hypomanic, I see connections between things. It's astonishing.
就像宇宙的结构似乎都连在了一起，这对我有意义。我能够对此进行写作。但当我处于躁狂时，我认为自己有了所有这些美妙的、宏大的想法，我把它们写在纸上。通常是用我能想象到的最微小的字体写出来的，等我不躁狂时，我就无法破译了。所以我大部分躁狂时的写作都付诸东流了。所以，调整药物以便能够保持在轻躁狂水平，因为它是有效的，这基本上是一个目标吗？这是凯·贾姆森（Kay Jamison）写过很多的一个话题。她是一位心理学家，也是一位作家。
It's like the fabric of the universe just seems to be connected and it makes sense to me. And I'm able to write about that. But when I'm manic, I think I have all these fabulous, grandiose ideas, and I put them down on paper. And it's usually in the tiniest imaginable little script that I can't decipher later when I'm not manic. So most of my manic writing has gone out the window. So is it a goal then to basically titrate the medicine so that you can sort of keep at that hypo level because it's effective? That's something that Kay Jameson has written a lot about. She was a psychologist and also a writer.
她谈到了寻找锂盐的最佳水平，这使她能够保留一些轻躁狂，同时仍能防止复发。这是一个平衡的艺术。对不同的人来说是不同的。你必须让你的医生认同拥有，你知道的，“我能服用较低水平的锂盐吗？”但对于一些艺术家来说，能够取得这种平衡是至关重要的。特里，我看到你写过关于你如何认为你的双相情感障碍导致你的行动非常受限，尤其是当你感到抑郁的时候。你能谈谈那个吗？比如，那是什么感觉？
She talked about finding the sort of optimal level of lithium that allowed her some hypomania but still protected against recurrences. And that is a balancing act. It's different for different people. You have to get your doctor on board with having, you know, can I take a lower lithium level? But for some people who are artists, that's very critical to be able to make that balance. Terry, I saw that you wrote about how you believe your bipolar disorder has led you to being very circumscribed in your movements, especially when you're feeling depressed. Can you talk about that? Like, what is that like?
你是如何发现自己在那个方面有些不同的？哦，金，我很高兴你提出这一点，因为这是我经常撰写的主题，而且我收到了关于这个主题最多的回应，因为我认为许多人正遭受着所谓的精神运动性迟缓，即抑郁状态下身体精神和身体过程的减慢。这太可怕了。这就像一种瘫痪。如果我，我正坐在我的桌子前，我想伸出手去拿我的笔，我都做不到。
And how did you discover that you were sort of different in that respect? Oh, Kim, I'm so glad you brought that up because that's something that I have written about frequently, and I've gotten the most responses to that subject because I think many people are suffering from what is called psychomotor retardation, a slowing down of the mental and physical processes of the body in depression. And it is terrifying. It's like a paralysis. If I were to, I'm sitting at my desk right now and I want to reach out and grab my pen, I couldn't do that.
我必须思考、思考、再思考。我的手仍然不听大脑的指挥。这就是精神运动性迟缓。我认为它确实没有得到它应该获得的关注，因为精神兴奋剂在这方面对我有所帮助，我认为其他人也可以从中受益，米克洛维茨博士可以对此进行探讨，但对我来说，这真的是患有双相情感障碍最糟糕的部分。是的，我实际上在想——我之前要问你这个，特里，这是否延伸到了早晨起床？你发现当你抑郁时，甚至连起床都非常困难吗？
I'd have to think about it and think about it and ponder it. And my hands still would not obey my mind. That's psychomotor retardation. And I think it really does not get the amount of attention that it should because I have been helped by psychostimulants with that and I think other people could be as well and Dr. Micklowitz could address that but it really is for me the worst part of being bipolar. Yeah and I wonder actually I was going to ask you this earlier Terry does that extend to the to getting out of bed in the morning do you find that when you're depressed it's very difficult to even move out of bed?
我抑郁时就生活在我的床上。我不怎么去除了厨房或浴室以外的地方，但不幸的是，床成了我的宇宙，因为你根本无法把，你无法掀开被子。它太重了。你有没有为这个特定问题找到任何有效的治疗方法？当它是非常严重的抑郁时，除了时间什么都帮不上忙。但当它没那么严重时，我再次发现精神兴奋剂是有帮助的，比如莫达非尼对我很有帮助。
I live in my bed when I'm depressed. I don't go much. further than the kitchen or the bathroom, but the bed becomes my universe, unfortunately, because you simply can't get the, you can't get the comforter off. It's too heavy. Have you found any effective treatments for that particular problem? When it's really severe depression, nothing helps but time. But when it's not quite as bad, again, I found that psychostimulants have been helpful, like modafinil helps me.
有时利他林（Ritalin）会有所帮助，或者所有这些药物的组合，连同我的心境稳定剂和我的抗抑郁药。所以我通过药物找到了一些帮助，但我希望有人能帮助我克服它会复发的恐惧，因为，再次强调，这是患有双相情感障碍最糟糕的部分。是的，我认为家人们最挣扎的事情之一就是他们会说：“好吧，如果你只是起床，你就会没事了。如果你只是，你知道的，强迫自己做事情，你会快乐得多。”然而他们不明白的是，当你带着双相情感障碍醒来时，就像胸口压了一百磅重的石头。
Sometimes Ritalin can be helpful or a combination of all of those and along with my mood stabilizers and my antidepressants. So I have found some help with the medication, but I wish someone could help with the terror of it returning because, again, it is the worst part of being bipolar. Yeah, and I think one of the things families struggle with most is they say, well, if you would just get out of bed, you'd be fine. And if you would just, you know, kind of make yourself do things, you know, you'll be a lot happier. Yet what they don't get is that when you wake up with bipolar disorder, it's like having a hundred pound weight on your chest.
你动不了。即使你愿意，即使你觉得你应该这么做，这也是一种很难克服的生理状态。家庭成员很难理解这一点。他们会说：“嗯，我今天早上起床了。你怎么就起不来？”但这是一个由抑郁症引起的严重的生理局限。这让我回到了以家庭为中心的治疗。我的意思是，当你做这个时，你用的一些技巧是什么？因为当爸爸妈妈说“孩子，快起床吧”，而孩子却起不来时，这肯定是患者听起来非常难受的话。所以，我的意思是，你如何引导家庭度过。
You can't move. Even if you want to, even if you feel like you should, it's a physical state that's very difficult. to overcome. And it's hard for family members to understand that. They said, well, I got up this morning. How come you can't? But it's, it is a serious physiological limitation that's brought on by depression. And that brings me back to family focused therapy. I mean, what are some of the techniques that you use when you do this? Because that's got to be something that is very hard for the the patient to hear when, you know, mom and dad are saying, just get out of bed, kiddo. And it's like the kid can't get out of bed. So, I mean, how do you walk the family through
这个过程并让父母提供帮助和理解？我认为任何时候听到这样的批评，你都必须从几个不同的角度去思考。你不能只是对父母摇摇手指说“不要批评”。你必须说，首先，他们的动机是好的。他们的动机是他们希望孩子更快乐。他们希望孩子更健康。他们希望他或她起床并能够完成学业。但他们表达的方式只会让孩子感到被否定。然后我们将与他们合作，你知道的，首先让我们了解为什么她在早上起床时会有这个困难。
that and get the parents to be helpful and understanding? I think anytime you hear criticism like that, you have to think about it in a couple of different ways. You can't just wag your finger at the parents and say, don't criticize. You have to say, first, their intention is a good one. Their intention is that they want the kid to be happier. They want them to be healthier. They want them to get or her to get out of bed and be able to finish school. But the way they're communicating it is in a way that's just going to feel invalidating to the child. And then we'll work with them on, you know, let's first let's understand why she has this problem getting up in the morning.
这是疾病的本质。其他患有这种疾病的人也有同样的问题。让我们设定一些较小的目标。比如，她能在这样一个时间间隔内，在这一小时内起床吗？如果她上学稍微迟到了一点，我们能跟学校协商接受这一点，或者不要在她每次上学迟到时都扣她分数吗？是否可以对药物进行调整，例如在前一天更早服用，这样她就不会在早晨产生睡眠。
That's the nature of the illness. other people who have this disorder have that same problem. Let's set some smaller goals. Like, can she get up within this interval, within this hour of time? If she's a little late to school, can we work it out with the school to accept that or to not dock her every time she shows up late to school? Are there adjustments to medications that could be made, taking them earlier, for example, in the previous day so that she doesn't have the sleep?
惯性，这实际上是在与家庭一起解决问题。还要让他们从孩子或年轻成年人的角度去理解这种感受，以及如何进行沟通。是的，我很乐意，我很乐意插话，米克洛维茨博士，因为根据我自己的经验，当你抑郁时，任何类型的建议都会被当作批评，因为任何说你“应该这样做”的人，天哪，如果我能的话，我难道不会去做吗？没有人愿意躺在那里被他们的被子困住。没错。
inertia in the morning, that's problem solving with the family, really. And also getting them to understand what it's like from the child's or the young adults' perspective and how to communicate about it. Yeah, I would love to, I'd love to jump in there, Dr. Mikulwitz, because I know from my own experience that any type of advice is going to come off as criticism when you're you're depressed because anyone who says you should do this, my God, if I could, wouldn't I be doing it? No one wants to be lying there trapped by their comforter. Right.
但我有一个关于如何沟通的建议，我写过并且对此深信不疑，也就是你刚才提到的。只需五个小词就能理解这个人正在经历什么：告诉我哪里疼。告诉我哪里疼。如果你对一个人这样说，并让他们敞开心扉，解释他们在黑暗和瘫痪中的感受，这会改变关系中的某些东西，也会改变抑郁症患者觉得自己孤立无援地面对疾病的感觉。我看到它无数次起作用，它对我也确实起作用。只需告诉我哪里疼。然后你必须倾听。那是困难的部分，而不是试图让一切都好起来。没错。我想硬币的另一面是。
But I have a suggestion for how to communicate that I've written about and I feel very strongly about, which you were just referencing. It's understanding what the person is going through by just five little words, tell me where it hurts. Tell me where it hurts. If you say that to a person and you let them open up and explain about how they're feeling in the darkness and the paralysis, it shifts something in the relationship and also in the depressed person's sense of being all alone with their disease. I've seen it work countless times and it certainly does work for me. Just tell me where it hurts. And then you've got to listen. That's the hard part and not try to make it all better. Right. I guess the flip side of that is
患有该疾病的人也必须愿意理解他们的父母正在经历的困惑。你知道的，他们会想，去年这个时候，你做得很好。为什么今年你起不来床了？有些父母拒绝这种疾病的概念。你知道的，这不可能是病。这只是懒惰。你不够努力。尽管这肯定对患病的本人没有帮助。父母正在经历他们自己的旅程，并试图弄清楚他们的孩子出了什么问题。嗯，我的父母不相信我患有双相情感障碍。不幸的是，他们去世时。
the person with the disorder has to also be willing to understand the confusion their parents are going through. You know, they last, last year this time, you were doing great. How come now this year you can't get out of bed? Some parents reject the idea of an illness. You know, this can't be an illness. This is just laziness. You're not trying hard enough. And although, that's certainly not helpful to the person with a disorder. Parents are kind of going through their own journey and trying to understand what's wrong with their kid. Well, my parents didn't believe I had bipolar disorder. And unfortunately, they died before.
真的，当时还没有今天这样对它的认知。但我认为这就是教育发挥作用的地方。每个人都不了解症状是没有借口的。这些迹象和简单的事情，比如你早上起床会有困难。现在有这么多关于双相情感障碍的书籍，还有这么多棒的，嗯，有这个播客，外面有这么多棒的教育例子。你只需要上网，开始了解症状、体征和诱因。然而它确实很难诊断。我的意思是，米克洛维茨博士，你能谈谈。
Really, there was a kind of awareness there is today about it. But I think this is where education comes in. There is no excuse for everybody not knowing the symptoms. the signs and think simple things like you're going to have trouble getting out of bed. There are so many books now about bipolar disorder and so many great, well, there's this podcast and there's so many great examples of education out there. You just have to go to the internet and start learning the symptoms and the signs and the triggers. And yet it's so it's hard to diagnose. I mean, Dr. Miklois, can you talk?
为什么它这么难诊断，因为，我的意思是，这听起来像是一个相当明确的综合征？所以，如果患者有清晰明确的躁狂发作与清晰明确的抑郁发作交替出现，那么诊断起来其实并不难。你可以获取病史，你可以听到，你知道的，过一遍症状清单。他们是否有其中的五个症状？这些症状是否持续了这么长时间？然后你就有了诊断。不幸的是，大多数患者的表现要比这模糊得多。他们同时具有躁狂和抑郁症状。他们有短发作与较长发作交替出现的情况。
about why it's so hard to diagnose because, I mean, it sounds like a pretty clear-cut syndrome. So if the person has a clear-cut manic episode alternating with clear-cut depressive episodes, it's not that hard to diagnose. It's, you can get the history, you can hear, you know, go through a checklist of symptoms. Do they have five of those symptoms? Have they lasted this amount of time? And you have your diagnosis. Unfortunately, most people, present in a much more ambiguous way than that. They have manic and depressive symptoms at the same time. They have short episodes alternating with longer episodes.
关于为什么这么难诊断，因为，我的意思是，听起来这是一个相当明确的综合征。所以，如果一个人有明确的躁狂发作，并与明确的抑郁发作交替出现，诊断其实并不那么难。你可以了解病史，你可以听听，你知道的，过一遍症状清单。他们有其中五种症状吗？这些症状持续了这么长时间吗？然后你就有了诊断。不幸的是，大多数人的表现要比这含糊得多。他们同时有躁狂和抑郁症状。他们的短发作与较长的发作交替出现。
They have hypomanias, sometimes and manias at other times. They have depressions that have some psychotic features. They also have ADHD and therefore I can't tell what part of this is hyperactive behavior due to the ADHD and what part of it is mania, where they have severe anxiety, which can look an awful lot like manic, over-stimulated thinking. So there's so many things that look like it. You have to take your time to do a diagnostic interview, a full diagnostic assessment. And unfortunately, the mental health system doesn't always allow for that.
他们有时会有轻度躁狂，有时会有躁狂。他们的抑郁伴有一些精神病性症状。他们还有注意力缺陷多动障碍（ADHD），因此我无法分清这其中的哪一部分是由于ADHD引起的多动行为，哪一部分是躁狂，他们会伴有严重的焦虑，这看起来非常像躁狂、过度刺激的思维。所以有很多事情看起来都很像。你必须花时间进行诊断性访谈，进行全面的诊断评估。而不幸的是，心理健康系统并不总是允许这样做。
And also, I think it's essential to have family input, and I'm sure Dr. Mikulwitz agrees, because you need to see a pattern. emerging over time and the best person for that or the best people for that are friends and family to really talk to the doctor and say, well, three months ago, she was talking so fast I couldn't understand her. You know, little clues like that are really what doctors need, I think. How did you finally get an accurate diagnosis, Terry? What would it take for that to happen? I had such bad depression that I had electroshock therapy. the depression was so severe. And in the middle of electroshock therapy, I escalated into the highest bout of mania I'd ever had. I spent every last cent I owned. I went up the coast to a
而且，我认为有家人的参与至关重要，我相信米库尔维茨博士也会同意，因为你需要看到一种随着时间推移逐渐显现的模式，而最好的人选或是最好的人选就是朋友和家人，他们可以真正地与医生交流并说，嗯，三个月前，她语速太快，我都听不懂。你知道，诸如此类的微小线索正是医生们真正需要的，我认为。特里，你是如何最终得到准确诊断的？这需要发生什么？我曾患有非常严重的抑郁症，以至于我接受了电休克疗法，因为抑郁症太严重了。在电休克疗法进行到一半时，我升级到了我经历过的最严重的躁狂发作。我花光了我拥有的每一分钱。我沿着海岸去了一家
five-star resort and just stayed there until my savings account was dry. I had a terrific time, but I had to come back and face the consequences, which was not so great. So it took my doctors seeing that and seeing, oh, yeah, I guess she gets manic. So maybe she's bipolar. That's what made the difference. So, Dr. Mikkelowitz, I want to ask you, what are the areas of research that you're most excited about right now in terms of improving treatment for people with bipolar disorder? What are the big questions that you would like to see answered? First, we're getting more and more interested in early intervention and prevention. If we can catch kids early enough who are just showing the early warning signs, particularly those who have a family history of the
五星级度假村，就呆在那里，直到我的储蓄账户见底。我玩得很开心，但我不得不回来面对后果，这可没那么好。所以，这需要我的医生看到这一点并看到，哦，是的，我想她确实会躁狂。所以也许她是双相情感障碍。这就是产生区别的原因。所以，米库尔维茨博士，我想问您，在改善双相情感障碍患者的治疗方面，您目前最兴奋的研究领域是什么？您希望看到哪些重大问题得到解答？首先，我们对早期干预和预防越来越感兴趣。如果我们能够足够早地发现那些刚开始出现早期预警信号的孩子，特别是那些有该病家族史的
disorder, we may be able to, if not prevent it, minimize the severity. And so we're going in with family psychoeducation for kids who are showing some manic symptoms, some depressive symptoms, and where bipolar disorder runs in the family. We've been able to show we can prevent depressive episodes or at least elongate the periods of wellness between mood episodes. Others have shown the same thing that early intervention may be one way to at least mollify the course of the disorder over time. We're also interested in the whole question of who gets better over time. We have a subgroup of kids. It's about 25 or 30 percent of the kids that we see in our clinic who start off and they look bipolar at the beginning. And by the time they're in
障碍，我们也许能够（如果不能预防的话）将严重程度降到最低。因此，我们正在为那些表现出一些躁狂症状、一些抑郁症状并且家族中有双相情感障碍病史的孩子开展家庭心理教育。我们已经能够证明，我们可以预防抑郁发作，或者至少延长情绪发作之间的健康期。其他人也证明了同样的随着时间的推移，早期干预可能是至少缓和疾病病程的一种方法。我们还对谁能随着时间的推移而好转整个问题感兴趣。我们有一组孩子。在我们诊所看病的孩子中，大约有25%或30%的人一开始看起来像双相情感障碍。到了
their early 20s or late teens, they're pretty stable, even when they're not taking medications. I don't know why that is. That's something I'd like to know, but other shops are finding that as well, that there's a subgroup that have a good outcome. Maybe it's protective factors. Maybe maybe we had the diagnosis wrong in the first place, or maybe they had a good relationship that protected them against mood variability. Those are things that we need to know. The other thing we're doing that I'm excited about is we've developed a child bipolar network, which is five or six different university sites. We're trying to put together common diagnostic and treatment guidelines for these kids. Like, what do you do when you have a kid who looks
他们20岁出头或十几岁快结束时，他们相当稳定，即使在不服药的情况下也是如此。我不知道为什么会这样。这是我想知道的事情，但其他机构也发现了这一点，即存在一个预后良好的亚组。也许是保护性因素。也许我们一开始诊断就错了，或者他们有一个良好的关系，保护他们免受情绪波动的影响。这些都是我们需要了解的事情。我感到兴奋的另一件事是我们建立了一个儿童双相情感障碍网络，由五六个不同的大学站点组成。我们正试图为这些孩子制定共同的诊断和治疗指南。比如，当你遇到一个孩子时，你该怎么办
bipolar, but the manic episode is due to antidepressants. How do you treat those kids versus somebody who has a longstanding bipolar disorder or has these mixed episodes? If we could all diagnose kids and treat them the same way, I think we'd be much further along or have a series of guidelines that everyone agrees upon. Last word, Terry, I'm going to ask from your vantage point, what would you like to see science and research illuminate, figure out, understand, and essentially resolve for people who are living with bipolar disorder? Well, I have a whole basket full of dreams about that. I would love to know more about psychedelics for bipolar disorder.
看起来像双相情感障碍，但躁狂发作是由抗抑郁药引起的。与长期患有双相情感障碍或有这些混合发作的人相比，你如何治疗这些孩子？如果我们都能以同样的方式诊断和治疗孩子，我认为我们会取得更大的进展，或者拥有一套每个人都同意的指南。最后一句话，特里，我想从你的角度问，你希望科学和研究能够阐明、弄清楚、理解，并从根本上为双相情感障碍患者解决什么问题？嗯，我对此有一大筐的梦想。我很想了解更多关于针对双相情感障碍的迷幻药的信息。
That really hasn't been explored much yet. I think there's great promise in the field of psychedelics. I think mindfulness also in its application to bipolar disorder could really help people. I'd like more addressing of the cost of medication. It's killing me. I'm sure it's killing other people out there. I am just on the edge of being not able to afford my medications, and it's very frightening. So I would like to see that researched.
这在很大程度上还没有被探索过。我认为迷幻药领域有着巨大的前景。我认为正念在应用于双相情感障碍时也能真正帮助人们。我希望更多地解决药物成本问题。这快把我压垮了。我相信这也快把其他人压垮了。我正处于无法承担药物费用的边缘，这非常可怕。所以我希望看到这方面的研究。
and addressed. And I'd like to see the stigma of having bipolar disorder reduced simply because it's not that bad a thing. You know, it's not like you're a terrible person. You're normal, quote, normal in between episodes. You're not always manic or always depressed. You know, you're just a human being with a brain that is hypersensitive to certain things and needs to be addressed by medication. So it really is not the shouldn't be getting the stigma that it does. I agree with that 100%. And also the issue about psychedelics, that is something we're interested in as well. Right now, psychedelics are only being used with major depression. They're not being used for bipolar disorder for what I think are obvious reasons. You don't want to kick off in manic episode. But I
并得到解决。我希望看到减少对患有双相情感障碍的污名化，仅仅是因为这并不是一件那么糟糕的事情。你知道，这并不意味着你是一个糟糕的人。在发作间期你是正常的，所谓“正常”。你并不总是躁狂或总是抑郁。你知道，你只是一个人类，你的大脑对某些事情过度敏感，需要通过药物来解决。所以这真的不是、不应该受到现在的这种污名化。我100%同意这一点。还有关于迷幻药的问题，这也是我们感兴趣的。目前，迷幻药只用于重度抑郁症。出于我认为显而易见的原因，它们不用于双相情感障碍。你不想引发躁狂发作。但是
I think there is a future for that kind of research, both with ketamine, psilocybin has been proposed, and it may be that a single or two sessions of that kind of drug can break through some barriers that people have in terms of their thinking, the ruminations and so on. I don't think it's a miracle, but I think we haven't studied it enough by any means. Well, it sounds like we've come a long way, but I would certainly have a very long way yet to go. I want to thank you both for joining me today. This has been really interesting. I appreciate particularly, Terry, you're putting yourself out there with your story because it's very, very compelling. Thank you, also, Dr. Micklewitts.
我认为这种研究是有未来的，无论是氯胺酮，还是有人提议的赛洛西宾（魔菇碱），可能一两次这种药物的疗程就可以打破人们在思维、反刍等方面的一些障碍。我不认为这是个奇迹，但我认为我们绝没有对其进行足够的研究所。嗯，听起来我们已经取得了很大的进展，但我们肯定还有很长的路要走。我要感谢你们两人今天加入我的节目。这真的非常有趣。特别是特里，我很感激你把你的故事讲出来，因为这非常非常有吸引力。也谢谢你，米库尔维茨博士。
You're quite welcome. Thank you, Kim. I really appreciate your having it here. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at W. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you aren't a regular subscriber, please sign up. Feel free to leave us a review as well. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology
不用客气。谢谢你，金。我真的很感激你邀请我来这里。你可以在我们的网站 www. speakingof psychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学之谈》之前的节目。如果你还不是定期订阅者，请注册。也欢迎给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以给我们发电子邮件：speaking of psychology
at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 APA.org。心理学之谈由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔迪安（Chris Condyenne）。感谢收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学会。该剧集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。